The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: Last time, we
talked about photochemistry.
And the crucial thing
in photochemistry
is that the density
of vibrational states
increases extremely rapidly--
extremely, extremely--
and especially
for larger molecules.
And this enables you to
understand intermolecular
vibrational redistribution,
intersystem crossing,
internal conversion.
The matrix elements
are different in each
of these cases.
But what happens when the
vibrational density of states
gets large is that you
have a special state, which
is a localized
state or something
that you care about that
you think you understand--
a bright state-- which is
different from the masses.
And because of the density
of states, that bright state
or that special
state, gets diluted
into an extremely dense manifold
of uninteresting states.
And as a result,
the system forgets
whatever the bright state
wanted it to tell you.
And so you get faster
decay of fluorescence,
not because the
population goes away,
but because the unique
thing-- the bright state,
the localized state-- the
thing that you can prepare
by excitation from the
ground state, which is always
localized, its
character is dissipated.
And so you get what's
called statistical behavior.
Now I have a very strong feeling
about statistical behavior,
and that it's mostly a fraud.
But the current limit
for statistical behavior
is when the density of
states is on the order of 100
per wave number.
That's the usual threshold
for statistical behavior.
As we know more, as we develop
better experimental techniques,
we're going to push that curtain
of statistical behavior back.
And we'll understand more
about the short-time dynamics
and whatever we want to do
about manipulating systems.
So statistical just
means we don't know,
but it's not what we expected.
And it's usually boring.
OK.
Today I'm going to talk
about the discrete variable
representation, which is really
weird and wonderful thing,
which is entirely inappropriate
for a course at this level.
But I think you'll like it.
So in order to talk about
the discrete variable
representation, I'll introduce
you to delta functions.
And you sort of know
what delta functions are.
And then I'm going to say,
well for any one-dimensional
problem--
and remember, you can have
a many-dimensional problem
treated as a whole bunch of
one-dimensional problems.
And so it really is
a general problem.
But if you have a
one-dimensional potential,
you can obtain the energy
levels and wave functions
resulting from that
one-dimensional potential.
Regardless of how
horrible it is,
without using perturbation
theory, which is
should make you
feel pretty good.
Because perturbation
theory is labor intensive
before you use the computer.
The computer helps you,
but this is labor free
because the computer
does everything.
At the beginning of
the course, I said,
you cannot experimentally
measure a wave function.
And that's true.
but if you can deal
with any potential
and have a set of experimental
observations, energy levels,
which you fit to an
effective Hamiltonian,
you can generate the
wave functions associated
with the effective
Hamiltonian directly
from experimental observations.
So it's not a
direct observation,
but you get wave functions.
And you can have whatever
complexity you want.
OK, so let's begin.
Delta functions.
So this is not the
Kronecker delta.
This is the delta
function that is
a useful computational trick.
And it's more than that.
We write something like this.
OK, this is a delta function.
And it says that this thing is
non-zero when x is equal to xi.
And it's really big.
And it's 0 everywhere else.
And as a result, you can say
that we get xi delta x xi.
So that's an
eigenvalue equation.
So we have the operator, x,
operating on this function.
And this function has
the magical properties
that it returns an
eigenvalue and the function.
So this is more than
a mathematical trick.
It's an entry into a
form of quantum mechanics
that is truly wonderful.
So this is part one.
Part two will be DVR--
discrete variable
representation.
And the issue varies.
Suppose we have a matrix
representation of an operator.
Well, suppose we wanted some
function of that operator.
How do we generate that?
And there are lots
of cases where
you care about such a thing.
For example, you
might want to know
about something like this--
e to the ih t over h bar.
This would tell you something
about how a system propagates
under the influence
of a Hamiltonian,
which is not diagonal.
This is kind of important.
Almost all of NMR is based
on this sort of thing.
Also-- well, we'll get to it.
So extend DVR to
include rotation.
And then the last part will be--
can be determined for even
the most horrible situations,
like a potential that
does something like this,
or something like that.
Now we don't want
to have a continuum.
So I put a wall here.
But this is a summarization
from an unstable isomer
to a stable isomer.
This is multiple minima.
Anything you want,
you would never
want to perturbation
theory on it.
And you can solve these problems
automatically and wonderfully.
OK, so let's just play
with delta functions.
And a very good section
on delta functions
is in Cohen-Tannoudji, and
it's pages 1468 to 1472,
right at the end of the book.
But it's not because
it's so hard,
it's just because they
decided to put it there.
And so we have notation--
x xi.
It's the same thing
as x minus xi.
So basically, if you see a
variable at a specified value,
it's equivalent to
this, and this thing
is 0 everywhere except
when x is equal to xi.
So the thing in parentheses
is the critical thing.
And it has the
property that if we
do an integral from minus
infinity to infinity,
some function of x--
dx-- delta x xi dx.
We get f of xi.
Isn't that wonderful?
I mean, it's a very
lovely mathematical trick.
But it's more than that.
It says this thing is big
when x is equal to xi.
It's 0 everywhere else.
And it's normalized
to 1 in the sense
that, well you get
back the function
that you started with,
but at a particular value.
So it's infinite,
but it's normalized.
It should bother you,
but it's fantastic
and you can deal with this.
It's an eigenvalue equation.
I mean, you can
say, all right, we
have delta x xi xi delta x xi.
And we can have delta functions
in position, in momentum,
in anything you want.
And they're useful.
So suppose we have some
function, psi of x,
and we want to
find out something
about how it's composed.
And so we say, well, we have
c of xi j delta x minus xi dx.
This is the standard method
for expanding a function.
OK, what we want is these
expansion coefficients.
And you get them in
the standard way.
And that is by--
normally, when you
have a function,
you write it ck j the function--
I'm sorry.
So here we have an
expansion of members
of a complete set of functions.
And in order to get the
expansion coefficients,
you do the standard trick of
integrating phi j star, psi j
dx.
OK, so this is familiar.
This is not.
But it's the same business.
In fact, we've been using
a notation incorrectly--
the Dirac notation.
We normally think that
if we have something
like k and psi k of x,
they're just different ways
of writing the same thing.
But the equivalent to
the Schrodinger picture
is really x psi.
This is a vector,
not a function.
This is a set of vectors.
And this is how you relate
vectors to functions.
We just have suppressed that.
Because it's easier to
think that the wave function
is equivalent to
the symbol here.
It's not.
And if you're going to
be doing derivations
where you flip back and forth
between representations,
you better remember this,
otherwise it won't make sense.
This is familiar
stuff, you just didn't
realize you understood it.
OK, and so now, often,
you want to have
a mathematical representation
of a delta function.
And so this thing
has to be localized
and it has to be normalized.
And there are a whole
bunch of representations
that work really well.
One of them is we
take the limit,
epsilon goes to 0 from
the positive side,
and 1 over 2 epsilon e to
the minus x over epsilon.
Well this guy, as
epsilon goes to 0,
this becomes minus infinity.
And it's 0 everywhere
except for x is equal to 0.
And so if we wanted to
put x minus xi, then fine.
Then it would be 0 everywhere
except when x is equal to xi.
So that's one.
That's a simple one.
Another one is limit
as epsilon goes
to 0 from the positive side of
1 over pi times epsilon over x
squared plus epsilon squared.
This also has the properties
of being an infinite spike at x
equals 0.
And it's also Lorentzian.
And it has the full width.
It'd have maximum-- or a
half width it would have--
a full width at half
maximum of epsilon.
If you make the width
as narrow as you want,
well that's what this is.
OK, there are a whole
bunch of representations.
I'm going to stop giving
them because there's
a lot of stuff I
want to say, and you
can see them in the notes.
OK, so what if we have
something like xi,
that just is the same thing
as saying x minus xi is 0.
You can produce a delta
function localized at any point
by using this trick.
OK, there are some
other tricks that you
can do with delta functions,
which is a little surprising.
And that's really
for the future.
Delta of minus x is
equal to delta of x.
It's an even function.
Derivative of a delta
function is an odd function.
Delta-- a constant times x
is 1 over the absolute value
of that constant, delta x.
A little surprising, but
if you have x, which--
I better not say that.
OK, we have now another
fantastic thing-- g of x.
So what is the delta
function of a function?
Well it's a sum over j of the
g ex and x of j times delta
x minus xj.
This is something
where you're harvesting
the zeros of this function.
OK, when this is 0,
we get a big thing.
So the delta function
of our function
is a sum over the derivative--
the zeros of g of x.
And at times, it's kind of neat.
OK, there's also stuff
in Cohen-Tannoudji
on Fourier transforms
of the delta functions.
I'm not going to
talk about that.
But one of the things is, if
you have a delta function and x,
and you take the Fourier
transformer with it,
you get a delta
function of p, momentum.
Kind of useful.
It enables you to do a transform
between an x representation
and a position representation
and a momentum representation.
It's kind of useful.
OK, now we're going to
get to the good stuff.
So for every system
that has a potential,
and where the
potential has minima,
what is the minimum potential?
What is the condition for
a minimum of the potential?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The first derivative
has to be 0 with respect
to coordinates.
ROBERT FIELD: Right.
And so, any time
you have a minimum,
the first term in the potential
is the quadratic term.
And that's the same thing
as a harmonic oscillator.
The rest is just excess baggage.
I mean, that's what we do
for perturbation theory.
We say, OK, we're going to
represent some arbitrary
potential as a
harmonic oscillator.
And all of the bad stuff,
all of the higher powers
of the coordinate get treated
by perturbation theory.
And you know how to do it.
And you're not
excited about doing it
because it's kind of
algebraically horrible.
And nobody is going
to check your algebra.
And almost guaranteed, you're
going to make a mistake.
(Exam 2!)
So it would be nice
to be able to deal
with arbitrary potentials--
potentials that might have
multiple minima, or might
have all sorts of strange
stuff without doing
perturbation theory.
And that's what DVR does.
So for example, we
want to know how
to derive a matrix
representation of a matrix.
So often, we have operators
like the overlap integral
or the Hamiltonian.
So we have the
operator, the S matrix,
or the Hamiltonian matrix.
And often, we want
to have something
that is a matrix
representation of a matrix.
For example, if we're dealing
with a problem in quantum
chemistry, where our basis
set is not orthonormal,
there is a trick
using the S matrix
to orthonormalize everything.
And that's useful because
then your secular equation
is the standard secular
equation, which computers just
love.
And so you just have
to tell the computer
to do something special before,
and it orthonormalizes stuff.
And you can do this
in matrix language.
And if you're interested
in time evolution,
you often want to have e to
the minus I h t over h bar.
And that's horrible.
But so we'd like to know how to
obtain a matrix representation
of a function of a matrix.
Well, suppose we
have some matrix,
and we can transform
it to be a1, a n, 0, 0.
We diagnose it.
And if a is real and
symmetric, or Hermitian.
We know that the
transformation that
diagonalized it has the
property that t dagger
is equal to the inverse.
And we also know that
if we diagonalize
a matrix the eigenvectors
that-- they say,
if you want the first
eigenvector, the thing that
belongs to this
eigenvalue, we want
the first column of t dagger.
And if you want to use
perturbation theory instead
of the computer to calculate
t dagger, you can do that,
and you have a
good approximation.
And you can write the vector,
the linear combination
of basis functions, that
corresponds to t dagger
as fast as you can write.
And the computer
can do it faster.
So if the matrix is Hermitian,
then all of these guys
are real.
And it's just real
and symmetric.
Well then these guys
are still numbers
that you could
generate, but they
might be imaginary or complex.
Suppose we want some
function of a matrix.
So this is a matrix, this
has to be a matrix too.
It has to be the same dimension
as the original matrix.
So you can do this.
Well we can call that f twiddle.
But we don't want f twiddle.
And so if we do this, we have
the matrix representation
of the function.
So this is something that could
be proven in linear algebra,
but not in 5.61.
You can do power
series expansions,
and you can show term
by term that this
is true for small
matrices, but it's true.
So if your computer
can diagonalize this,
then what happens is
that we have this--
we can write that
f twiddle is the--
So this is the crucial thing.
We've diagonalized
this, so we have
a bunch of eigenvalues of a.
So the f twiddle
is just the values
of the function at each
of the eigenvalues.
And we have zeros here.
And now we don't like
this because this isn't
the matrix representation of f.
It's f in a different
representation.
So we have to go back to
the original representation.
And so that's another
transformation.
But it uses the same matrix.
So if you did the
work to diagonalize a,
well then you can go back
and undiagonalize this
f twiddle to make the
representation of f.
And so the only work involved
is asking the computer
to find t dagger
for the a matrix.
And then you get the true
matrix representation
of this function of a.
Is it useful?
You bet.
Now suppose a is
infinite dimension.
And we know that this
is a very common case.
Because, even for the
harmonic oscillator,
we have an infinite
number of basis functions.
But what about using
the delta function?
We also have an
infinite number of them.
So what do we do?
We can't diagonalize
an infinite matrix.
So what we do is we truncate it.
Now the computer is quite
happy to deal with matrices
of dimension 1,000.
Your computer can
diagonalize a 1,000
by 1,000 matrix in a few
minutes, maybe a few seconds
depending on how up
to date this thing is.
And so what we do is we say, oh,
well let's just take a 1,000.
So here is an infinite matrix.
And here is a 1,000
by 1,000 block.
That's a million elements.
The computer doesn't care.
And we're just going to
throw away everything else.
We don't care.
Now this is an approximation.
Now you can truncate
in clever ways,
or just tell the computer to
throw away everything above
the 1,000th basis function.
That's very convenient.
The computer doesn't care.
Now there are
transformations that say,
well you can fold in the effects
of the remote basis states,
and do an augmented
representation.
But usually, you just
throw everything away.
And now you look at this
1,000 by 1,000 matrix.
And you get the eigenvalues.
And so this might be
the matrix of x, or q
if we're talking in
the usual notation.
This is the displacement
from equilibrium.
Well, it seems a little--
so we would like to
find this matrix.
Well, we know what that is.
Because we know the relationship
between x and a plus
a dagger are friends.
And so we have a matrix, which
is zeros along the diagonal,
and numbers here and here,
and zeros everywhere else.
It doesn't take much
to program a computer
to fill in as many one-off
the diagonal, especially
because they're square
roots of integers.
So that's just a
few lines of code,
and you have the matrix
representation of x.
Now that is infinite.
And you're going to
say, well, I don't care.
I'm going to just
keep the first 1,000.
We know that we
can always write--
so we have v of x, and
this is a matrix now.
And it's an infinite matrix.
But we say, oh, we just
want v of x to the 1000th,
and we'll get v of 1,000.
We have a 1,000
by 1,000 v matrix.
And we know how to do this.
We diagonalize that.
Then we write at each
eigenvalue of x, what v of x
is at that eigenvalue.
And so now we have a v
matrix, which is diagonal,
but in the wrong
representation for us.
And then we transform back
to the harmonic oscillator
representation.
And so everything is fine.
We've done this.
And we don't know how
good it's going to be.
But what we do is
we do this problem.
So we have the
Hamiltonian, which
is equal to the
kinetic energy, I'm
going to call it
k, plus v. We know
how to generate the
representation of v
in the harmonic oscillator
basis by writing v
of x, diagonlizing x, and
then undiagonalizing--
or then writing v at each
of the eigenvalues of x,
and then going back to the
dramatic oscillator basis.
We know k in the harmonic
oscillator basis.
It's just tri-diagonal,
and it has
matrix elements delta v
equals 0 plus minus two.
So now we have a
matrix representation
of k, which is simple,
add a v which is--
computer makes it simple.
Add any v you want, there it is.
So that's a matrix,
the Hamiltonian.
You solve the
Schrodinger equation
by diagonalizing this matrix.
And so you have this h matrix,
and it's for the 1,000-member x
matrix, and you get a
bunch of eigenvalues.
And so then you do it again.
And maybe use a 900 by 900,
or maybe you use a 1,100--
you do it again.
And then you look
at the eigenenergies
of the Hamiltonian,
e1, say, up to e100.
Now if you did a
1,000 by 1,000, you
have reasonable expectation
that the first 100
eigenvalues will be right.
And so you compare the results
you get for the 1,000 by 1,000
to the 900 by 900,
or 1,100 by 1,100.
And you see how accurate
your representation
is for the first 100.
Normally, you don't even
care about the first 100.
You might care about 10 of them.
So the computer is happy to
deal with 1,000 by 1,000s.
There's no least
squares fitting,
so you only do it once.
And all of a sudden,
you've got the eigenvalues,
and you've demonstrated
how accurate they are.
And so depending on what
precision you want--
you can trust this up to the
100th, or maybe the 73rd,
or whatever, to a part in
a million, or whatever.
And so you know how
it's going to work.
And you have a check
for convergence.
So it doesn't matter.
So the only thing
that you want to do
is you want to choose a
basis set where we have--
x is the displacement
from equilibrium.
OK, so this is the
equilibrium value.
This is the definition
of the displacement.
And so you want to
be able to choose
your basis set, which is
centered at the equilibrium
value.
You could do it somewhere
else, it would be stupid.
It wouldn't converge so well.
And you want to use the
harmonic oscillator, k over u.
You have a couple of choices
before you start telling
the computer to go to work.
And you tell it, well
I think the best basis
that will be what works
at the equilibrium--
the lowest minimum
of the potential,
and matches the curvature there.
You don't have to do that.
But it would be a
good idea to ask
it to do a problem that's likely
to be a good representation.
And all this you've done.
You get the energy level.
So what you end up getting--
So you produced
your Hamiltonian.
And since it's not an infinite
dimension Hamiltonian,
we can call it an
effective Hamiltonian.
It contains everything
that is going
to generate the eigenvalues.
And we get from that a
set of energy levels--
e vi-- and a set of functions.
So these guys are the
true energy levels.
And these are the
linear combinations
of harmonic oscillator
functions that
correspond to each of them.
Who gives that to you?
And so then you
say, well, I want
to represent the Hamiltonian
by a traditional thing.
Like, I want to say that we have
omega v plus 1/2 minus omega x
equals 1/2 squared, et cetera.
Now we do a least squares
fit of molecular constants
to the energy levels
of the Hamiltonian.
And there's lots of other
things we could do, but--
so we say, well in the spectrum,
we would observe these things,
but we're representing them as
a power series in v plus 1/2.
Or maybe in-- where we would
have not just the energy--
the vibrational quantum number--
but the rotational constant.
We could say the potential is
v of 0 plus b x j j plus 1.
Well, that means we could extend
this to allow the molecule
to rotate.
And we just need to evaluate
the rotational constant
as a function of x, and just
add that to what we have here.
Another thing, you have t
dagger and t for our problem.
And you have, say,
the 1,000 by 1,000,
and maybe the 900 by
900 representations.
You keep them.
Because any problem you would
have, you could use these for.
So you still have to
do a diagonalization
of the Hamiltonian,
but the other
stuff you don't
have to do anymore.
Now maybe it's too bothersome to
store a 1,000 by 1,000 t dagger
matrix.
It's a million elements.
Maybe you don't, and you
can just calculate it again.
It takes 20 minutes
or maybe less.
And so this is a pretty good.
OK I've skipped a lot of
stuff in the notes, because I
wanted to get to the end.
But the end is really
just a correction
of what I said was impossible
at the beginning of the course.
We have in the
Schrodinger picture
H psi is equal to E psi, right?
That's the Schrodinger equation.
So this wave function
is the essential thing
in quantum mechanics.
And I also told you,
you can't observe this.
So it's a very
strange theory where
the central quality
in the theory
is experimentally inaccessible.
But the theory works.
The theory gives you
everything you need.
It enables you to find
the eigenfunctions,
if you have the
exact Hamiltonian.
Or it says, well we can
take a model problem
and we can find the
eigenvalues and wave functions
for the model problem.
We can generate an
effective Hamiltonian,
which is expressed in terms
of molecular constants.
We can then determine
the potential.
And we can also determine psi.
All of them.
So what I told you was
true, but only a little bit
of a lie in the sense that
you can get as accurate
as you want a representation
of the wave function,
if you want it.
And DVR gives it to
you without any effort.
And so it doesn't matter
how terrible the potential
is, as long as it is more
or less well behaved.
I mean, if you had
a potential, which--
Even if I had a v potential--
the discontinuity here--
you would still get a
reasonable result from DVR.
What it doesn't
like is something
like that, because then you
have a continuum over here.
And the continuum uses up your
basis functions pretty fast.
I mean, yeah, it
will work for this.
But you don't quite know
how it's going to work,
and you have to do very
careful convergence tests,
because this might be good.
But up here, it's going to
use a lot of basis functions.
So for the first
time in a long time,
I'm finishing on time
or even a little early.
But DVR is really a
powerful computational tool
that, if you are doing any kind
of theoretical calculation,
you may very well much want
to use something like this
rather than an infinite
set of basis functions
and perturbation theory.
It's something where you
leave almost all of the work
to the computer.
You don't have to do
much besides say, well
what is the equilibrium value?
And what vibrational
frequency have
I got to use for my basis set?
And if you choose
something that's
appropriate for the curvature
at the absolute minimum
of the potential, you're
likely to be doing very well.
Now other choices might mean
you don't get the first 100,
you only get the first 50.
But you might only care
about the first 10.
Or you could say, I'm
going to choose something
which is a compromise
between two minima,
and maybe I'll do better.
But it doesn't cost you
anything in the computer.
Your computer is mostly
sitting idly on your desk,
and you could have it
doing these calculations.
And there is no problem
where you can't use DVR.
Because if you have a
function of two variables,
you do a two-variable DVR.
It gets a little
bit more complicated
because, if you
have two DVRs, now
you're talking about a million--
1,000 by 1,000-- two of them,
and couplings between them.
And so maybe you have
to be a little bit more
thoughtful about how
you employ this trick.
But it's a very powerful trick.
And there are other
powerful tricks
that you can use in conjunction
with quantum chemistry that
enable you to deal
with things like--
I've chosen a basis set,
which is not orthonormal.
And my computer only
knows how to diagonalize
an ordinary Hamiltonian
without subtracting
an overlap matrix from it.
And so if I transform to
diagonalize the overlap matrix,
well then I can fix the problem.
And so there is a way of
using this kind of theory
to fix the problem,
which is based
on choosing a convenient way of
solving the problem, as opposed
to the most rigorous
way of doing it.
OK, so I'm hoping
that I will have
a sensible lecture on
the two-level problem
for Wednesday.
I've been struggling with
this for a long time.
And maybe I can do it.
If not, I'll review
the whole course.
OK, see you on Wednesday.